our minds are they're
pliable everyone's minds are pliable and
it's different levels some people have
more pliable Minds than others
but our minds are pliable and we get
influenced by our environment that's
what happens music words that you read
movies books social media the the news
the people you're around family
friends people that you work with you're
getting influenced that's what's
happening think about how you feel when
you hear some aggressive
music think about what that does to your
mindset you hear aggressive music and
you start feeling a little bit amped up
or you hear some sappy
music or some party type music it
impacts you it influences the way you're
thinking move
movies can change your mood right I mean
everyone's felt that you watch some
movie it's a happy movie it's a sad
movie it's an action
movie it influences the way you're
thinking you your
friends you got friends that like to
party right they like to go out they
like to drink and go out to the clubs
you're around those people all a sudden
you start feeling that little
urge and you got other friends that are
disciplined they are going to go to the
gym early in the morning they make you
want to work
out so these are examples that we might
not be thinking about them but if you
think about them you know they're
obvious and this is happening all day
long this is happening all day long our
minds
are morphing from minute to
minute if we let
them
if you are not paying attention if you
are on cruise control then your your
mind is not under your own control we
can't be in cruise control you can't let
your mind be in cruise control you have
to be cognizant of what you're
thinking you have to be cognizant you
have to be
aware of how you are being
influenced because in this day and age
right now if you aren't careful
you can slide down the path of least
resistance the
path path to
weakness the path to
fragility and the path to a lack of
control as to what is happening in our
lives in your
life life will happen to
you instead of Life happening for
you
do not allow that just do not allow
that you have to take
control you you've got to do something
to get control of your brain of your
mind you got to check yourself I don't
care how you do it I don't care if you
if you set an alarm every 45 minutes so
you can audit your thoughts so you can
audit what is influencing you so you can
control what's influencing you control
the things you think
about you can actually control how you
feel you can control what you think and
you can definitely control what you
do do not be a slave to
influence you got to be the master of
your mind you got to control your mind
you got to exercise mind
control that means you got to pay
attention and be aware all
day that's what you got to
do so go
execute